hey guys
my name is akshay bhadha uh today i'll
be talking about my
uh my research project indian sign
language recognition system
also called uh before we start uh
just want to give a brief introduction
about myself so i'm currently working as
a senior
data scientist at lowe's i'm also over
developer expert
machine learning i received the most
influential young data scientist of the
year award in 2019
i was awarded a top intel innovator
award in 2019
i've been invited for over 50 sessions
and keynotes uh on machine learning
so these are these are some of the
snippets from the conferences you can
see
uh i've been to a couple of conferences
sharing my work and this research
project is based
is an outcome of of getting those
experience
when going out there so before we start
an important link for everyone so if you
want to follow along or if you want to
get some references
uh to the sites just go to bit.ly
slash file type and query and you will
be ready
redirected to my github page which has
this repository
and you can just click on the links or
the slides and follow along
or you can even open some
issues on the on the github itself on
the deposit if you have any questions
so that in mind let's start with the
project
uh so let's start with the definition so
the project demonstrates
the use of machine learning to develop
and analyze
an indian sign language technique system
so these two terms develop and
standardize are important for us
uh we'll discuss about these two terms
specifically in
in some of the latest slides uh let's
move along
so now we are defining our problem
statement so some of the
so i did some research initial research
about
uh around 16 months back about about the
scope of our project
so what i realized is that 40 million
people in india apparently suffering
from speech and hearing and pain
uh 80 kilometers is a different distance
between mumbai and pune
two major cities in in in maharashtra
uh these these are the places that i
work and i live respectfully like my
hometown
uh and within 80 kilometers the sign
language has
uh very uh significant changes
so let's come up with an ideal solution
so based on my research uh the ideal
solution
had some key features first i was
like american sign language so american
sign language is standardized
uh within the u.s so anybody who's a
definite can
the definite person can travel from and
to and from different states
without having to learn a different
version of sign language
uh also can we leverage ai to accurately
predict minor changes in signs and
symbols so this is where ai or machine
learning
becomes very effective we have to be
able to generalize so well
uh to the data at hand but it's most
important for me
was to keep the resource intensive to a
bare minimum
uh this will ensure that i could scale
my model
i could uh reach these out to people who
are not uh living in very harsh areas
but they still
want to make use of this technology so i
did not use any
uh internet or heavy gpus or any
external hardware
because i wanted to keep this accessible
to the
to most of the people so the methodology
that i followed
uh was to actually categorize the
problem into
three different subcategories so if i
knew
about the hand movement if i knew about
the facial expressions
and if i had some idea about the pose of
the person
i could come up with an interpolation so
this was my thought process
and what i did was i divided my work
into different phases
so this comes a development part um and
this is where i actually went
to an end view i studied sign language
for six to seven months
and this is a video from that ngo so
these are some of the students from the
ngo who have
been a student as well as they are uh
also now uh learning uh uh i mean
they're part of the sign language
community in india
and they and these guys really help me
and my friends to
know about sign language and what are
the problems that they have faced
and how can uh as a uh how can us as a
community improve
their uh their standard of living
so uh you can find the whole video on my
youtube channel uh so i divided the
working phases as already
so phase zero uh was only working at add
gestures
so as you can see i'm only working with
hand gestures uh so these are different
uh different digits and different
alphabets
so these are different interpretations
for different alphabets
and that's overweight for missing so i
use image processing and degrading that
with machine learning
uh to come up with an application that
that could
um you know that could interpret these
much these
sign languages in runtime as you can see
i'm only working with alphabets and
digits
therefore the model is not very complex
now the phase one was uh was i've
already discussed
facial expressions were very important
for us so
i came up with this algorithm of using
sign language
of using hand gestures as well as facial
key points
uh to make our model more robust
and the results were really promising so
as you can see that i'm only working
with
a uh a skeleton image so on the right
you see
uh my favorite key point factoring
mechanism as well as my hand gesture
mechanism
so even though there are a lot of
background noise in the on in the
in the same i'm only working with just
some key aspects
and this made my model to be lightweight
and including scary
uh activities millions of people
then i use uh i came up with another
technique uh
this is so this is integrating will
texture speech
uh so this will make sure that i could
be here to more people
so you can check out the whole video
about about this process on my
youtube channel and one of the one of
the
very interesting things that happened
was i was invited by google
uh by google with the headquarters in
california and i got a chance to present
my work with the tensorflow team itself
here's a small slim bit of it
so you can have a look at the whole
video uh if you are really interested
it's on my youtube channel
and it's around seven to eight minutes
um where i got a chance to
just give an elevator pitch of my
project and
i also got good feedback from the
community and relevant that's a
theme on how i could improve this on on
this application
so uh with that i would like to end my
session
if you have any questions simply reach
out to me if you have any feedback for
my presentation or for my application if
you feel that i
could improve certain aspects if you do
that feel free to reach out to me at
akshayabharal.com uh where you can just
drop your comments
or some references i will have a look at
that i will definitely get back to you
as quickly as possible so once again
thank you so much for listening to me my
name is akshay bahadur
uh you can follow me on twitter at
accepted me you can even follow me on my
personal website akshaya
guru.com and if you want to try to
uh get if you want to get all the
information about this session
go to windows slash by dive and 20 this
is where i have other sites and all the
references
so with this i would like to thank each
and every one of you for listening to me
i hope you guys are keeping safe and i'm
also hoping that we meet
soon in person take care of yourself bye